Similar to Jeffrey, I
have my own challenges
with my disability.
And I felt like there's
a need for more people
to be working on technologies
in rehabilitation engineering--
exoskeletons being one
of them, wheelchair
designs, and other kind
of adaptive equipment.
So that's kind of how I
got into wanting to do
rehabilitative engineering.
The whole story really
started 18 years ago
when Jeffrey got sick, and he's
worked every day for 18 years
to get better.
As his caregiver,
and his mother,
how could I do anything
but help him every day?
And so last summer we
were talking about it,
and I had made a variety
of projects myself,
but this was going to
be a little bit more
than what I could do in the
garage between Ace Hardware,
hire a welder.
And I called the engineering
department and they said,
you know what, why
don't you see if you
can sign up to do a project.
We put out a letter, email,
and stuff to friends,
and they just all came together.
The $10,000 was way
surpassed for the fee
to get into this program.
This project has so much heart.
And engineering, you
know, this is really
improving the life
of a human being.
And that's, as a
biomedical engineer,
that's kind of
our goal, too, you
know-- just using
engineering principles,
mathematical principles,
science principles in order
to improve human health.
And I really feel
like that's what
we're doing with this project.
The ultimate goal is to
run with the exoskeleton
that the team has made.
It's been a really long,
exciting, and beneficial
journey for everyone involved.
You're OK.
Here, now, if you grab
his foot there, Thomas--